[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes au Sénégal où une méthode
unique au monde est en cours
une association pour le sourire d'un
enfant qui s'occupe des enfants en
situation de conflit avec la loi utilise
un sport étonnant magique pour les aider
à se réinsérer ce sport c'est les screen
[Musique]
c'est ta tiesse à 70 km de Dakar que
j'ai rencontré Nelly Robin elle est à
l'initiative de cette méthode inédite
tout a commencé il y a 25 ans quand j'ai
découvert cette femme lors d'un
documentaire que je faisais avec mon
père sur les enfants des rues
lundi 10 janvier 2000 il est 10h du
matin nous sommes en train de rouler
vers la gare de Thiers
des gamins ont en effet signalé à Nelly
la présence d'un enfant qui traîne sur
les voies ferrées
il y a des enfants
[Musique]
25 ans plus tard l'association inélie
continue leur combat et leur méthode
donnent des résultats qui dépassent
toutes les espérances
aujourd'hui l'association a été appelée
pour récupérer un enfant
[Musique]
comment il vous a été confié cet enfant
qui a été très probablement trouvé dans
la rue par une personne
qui l'a conduit à la police le la police
l'a signalé
au service de l'enfance du tribunal qui
nous ont appelés pour nous le confier
conformément à l'agrément que nous avons
avec le ministère de la Justice et puis
cet enfant est conduit dans le foyer
d'accueil qui existe depuis 30 ans il
sera entièrement pris en charge par les
éducateurs
[Musique]
cicatrices
il a été torturé par qui
[Musique]
il va partir avec moi
mais j'ai fait plus que enseigner
bon je suis là comme une maman qui
essaie de combler le vite affecté qu'il
manque aux enfants
je suis là comme une maman dans sa
famille avec ses enfants tout ce que une
maman a fait dans une maison dans une
famille avec ses enfants je le fais oui
je m'occupe de l'hygiène vestimentaire
corporelle des chambres tout tout tout
[Musique]
[Rires]
et voici madame Tiane qui est en train
de contrecarrer Mbappe sur le terrain
[Musique]
l'association travaille aussi sur le
terrain de foot de la ville ou de
nombreux enfants se retrouvent chaque
jour la plupart sont des talibés ce sont
des enfants confiés à des chefs
religieux appelés marabout
[Musique]
autre personnage emblématique de
l'association c'est Jacques Jacques
travaille dans l'association depuis 30
ans il s'occupe des enfants alibés en
étroite collaboration avec les marabouts
dans différentes écoles coraniques ce
sont les rats
avec le temps il est devenu éducateur de
la méthode escrime et justice
réparatrice en Afrique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de violence
qui sont en bas de sur l'intolérance
l'ouverture de Tcherno
vis-à-vis de nous vis-à-vis du travail
avec chaque c'est un magnifique exemple
et que on puisse dire aujourd'hui dans
notre monde que il y a des lieux comme
ça c'est très important Jacques il est
chrétien c'est un secret pour personne
tiens-nous il est musulman c'est un
secret pour personne mais c'est avant
tout des hommes
qui sont là pour les enfants et c'est
pour ça qu'il se rencontre et je trouve
que dans le monde actuel c'est un
message extrêmement important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est là c'est la méthode
devant le travail
il y a tout l'exposé des principes de la
méthode
et c'est suivi de la description de
60 leçons qui sont développés avec les
mineurs voilà super trop oui oui c'est
quand même
c'est une première pour l'association
c'est aussi l'illustration de la qualité
du partenariat avec l'administration
pénitentiaire donc voilà c'est
c'est un instant fort
l'ambassadeur de France a voulu se
rendre au sein de la prison pour
découvrir et tenter de comprendre cette
méthode révolutionnaire comment les
screen peut être aussi bénéfique pour
les mineurs
intrigué par cette méthode auprès des
détenus l'ambassadeur a voulu rencontrer
le personnel pénitent
la prévention de la récidive depuis
l'expérience avec l'amour
à réduire ce qu'on appelle
d'escrime on peut dire que depuis lors
on ne reçoit plus dans la dans la prison
on intervient à la prise de test depuis
1991 on a reconstruit la grande
détention adulte en 1998 le premier
quartier mineur
ensuite on a construit un second
quartier mineur plus VIP on va dire on
avait créé le quartier femme parce que
au départ la prison de Thiès n'était pas
destinée à recevoir des femmes petit à
petit elles sont arrivées et donc on
avait aménagé un quartier femme dans un
magasin que vous aviez eu la gentillesse
de mettre à notre disposition
dernièrement on a construit un quartier
femme en essayant de mettre en place un
petit espace pour les femmes qui ont
leur bébé qui souvent s'imposent des
petites difficultés puis on est à la
disposition de la MAC en fonction des
besoins hospitalisations accouchement
enfin voilà ce qui est nécessaire
vraiment une passionnée de la de la
prison et à chaque fois que de poser un
qu'on fait appel à elle bon et n'hésite
pas
ce n'est ni la date
si on a pu faire tout cela c'est parce
que l'administration pénitentiaire a
ouvert ses portes et que parvenir à
construire ce ce niveau de collaboration
de ça reflète la disponibilité de
l'administration pénitentiaire et son
souci de l'attention ou détenus on vous
invite à voyager mais notre vie c'est un
bus
vous voyez il est pas très fort
partager merci à vous merci pour votre
accueil merci beaucoup salut
[Musique]
ça te rappelle des souvenirs
il était alors prisonnier et accusé
d'associations de malfaiteurs il a
pratiqué l'escrime au sein de
l'association et aujourd'hui ils sont
les sorties de manière admirable
maintenant c'est fini c'est fini pour
moi parce que je suis foutu
mais pourquoi pas
de faire ma ville normalement
comme comme je peux le faire en escrime
donc je préfère d'avoir vie et je me
suis retrouvé
[Musique]
du plaisir que du plaisir et que
beaucoup de plaisirs et beaucoup de
souvenirs avec les
anciens amis
[Musique]
ça va améliorer ça m'a beaucoup amélioré
ça va l'esprit
pourquoi ça t'a amélioré l'esprit
parce que
je m'énerver je m'énerve vite
quand même par mes parents me parle je
ne l'écoutais pas je faisais
en prison
j'ai commencé à faire l'escrime
petit à petit je commence à m'améliorer
avoir de respect envers les autres
envers
aucun enfant passait par ce programme
n'a récidivé comment peut-on arriver à
une telle efficacité et pourquoi
l'escrime et non pas un autre sport
ça fait très longtemps
qu'on travaille avec les mineurs en
détention et on s'est aperçu que ces
jeunes arrivaient dans des situations de
plus en plus complexes
les garçons particulièrement
accusés d'associations de malfaiteurs et
puis les filles de plus en plus
accusées d'apprentisser et d'avortement
et on s'est dit que pour ces jeunes il
fallait essayer de proposer quelque
chose qui leur permettent de retrouver
l'estime de soi
de contrôler aussi un petit peu leur
colère et de reconstruire leur identité
[Musique]
moi je l'avais observé dans des clubs
d'escrime en France que des enfants qui
étaient plus qui caractéristiques
quelquefois très caractériel lorsqu'ils
sur une piste d'escrime leur
personnalité se transformait c'est à
dire ils acceptaient les règles de
l'esprit
marcher
et quand les deux problématiques que
j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure se sont
posées
et que l'objectif c'était d'éviter la
récidive parce qu'on était sur des
jeunes qui pouvaient avoir jusqu'à 7 8
récidives
et à ce moment là je me suis dit mais
peut-être que l'escrime c'est une piste
à explorer au début quand même comme les
autres collègues je crois que je ne suis
pas seul
on était en politique parce que
on était pas informé
[Musique]
il faut
inquiétude je me disais que comment
peut-on pratiquer l'escrime américain
le fleuret je me disais mais les gens là
ils peuvent se blesser avec ça c'est
énorme je vais pas compris mais quand
j'ai fait l'escrime j'ai vu que vraiment
personne ne peut se blesser avec ça
c'est là que j'ai compris à d'accord
donc ça ce n'est pas une arme mais c'est
un
c'est quelque chose qu'on utilise pour
faire le sport
c'est une histoire pour deux choses
entre l'être humain et la
d'accord là on est tenu par la main bien
sûr le bras et c'est le prolongement de
mon esprit c'est toi qui compte leur là
tu peux te contrôler toi-même
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut préciser c'est que la
pratique de l'esprit y compris pour les
mineurs en détention dans cette méthode
s'effectue à l'extérieur de la prison
nous au début on a souhaité cela parce
que on restait attachés au fait que
normalement selon les droits de l'homme
les mineurs ne doivent pas aller en
prison donc si on doit alors proposer
quelque chose c'est à l'extérieur de la
prison l'autre objectif c'est qui puisse
pratiquer aussi après leur temps de
détention donc sont limités la pratique
de l'escrime dans l'espace carcéral ils
ne peuvent pas venir après le temps de
détention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je devrais être au bain ou bien non mais
l'esprit
la liberté
ça c'est une autre chose c'est autre
chose
pour aller faire l'esprit on disait on
part au Sénégal
parce que le Président c'est au Sénégal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui a gagné
ça change beaucoup de choses pour moi
exemple tu es en prison six mois tu
parles pas avec un mec mais maintenant à
cause de l'escrime je parle avec tout le
monde parce que je viens ici je le parle
on fait des combats et tout à cause de
ça ils sont devenus des amis
et au début je me disais à chaque fois
qu'il pouvait partir
mais maintenant
il y a un climat de confiance qui s'est
établi entre ces détenus et moi à chaque
fois je l'ai taquiner en leur disant
mais les enfants il faut pas partir et
il répond nous n'allons pas partir
[Musique]
on lève la main quand on est touché
vous touche à vous lever la main et lui
aussi il doit faire la même chose ça les
enfants à accepter quand on a fait des
bêtises à accepter de dire que j'ai
commis une bêtise
[Musique]
comme vous le savez nous avons un
agrément de la justice depuis 1994 qui
nous permet de participer à l'audience
des mineurs où nous avons une voix
consultative mais nous avons remarqué
que les mineurs qui pratiquent l'escrime
devant la barre
pas à le déclaration et les magistrats
disent
l'enfant qui ne varie pas à sa
déclaration de l'enquête préliminaire
jusqu'à l'audience cet enfant-là est
prêt à s'amender donc pour vous dire que
tous les enfants qui pratiquent
l'escrime et une fois qu'ils sont en
audience donc ils sont à la ils sont
libérés
[Musique]
bon ça ça sur le site l'ouverture
d'esprit la communication
[Musique]
en fait de ce match je véhicule et des
messages lorsque une personne parfois
tombe c'est à moi d'arrêter le match
lorsqu’une personne est blessée c'est un
modèle tellement c'est en fait c'est une
responsabilité qui qui était lourde à
quelque sorte dans ma tête et que
à tous toujours devoir comment gérer le
match et comment même organiser les
tournants
être arbitre ça veut dire qu'il y a un
certain responsabilité ça veut dire
qu'on vous fait confiance en fait
confiance à votre jugement
parce que tout simplement ça le permet
de multiplier leur position
à l'instant dans le sport dans l'escrime
mais dans la société future c'est à dire
que ils sont pas ils seront pas toujours
à confronter à corps à corps on
vis-à-vis mais ils seront appelés aussi
à pouvoir trancher prendre des décisions
deux trois un gars
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
allez voilà voilà
[Musique]
je dois pas avoir une haine contre lui
parce que c'est le jeu
[Musique]
mais c'est juste
leur permet de laver d'oublier ce qu'ils
avaient déjà combien compétition et qui
les a conduits en prison
[Musique]
symbolisme très très fort ils sont tous
en blanc et pour tous des masques donc
il y a une certaine uniformité qui font
qu'ils sont tous pareils tous égaux
[Musique]
c'est des jeunes qui sont en pleine
construction d'identité donc on a
travaillé là-dessus sur comment chacun
peut construire individuellement son
identité et n'a pas besoin du regard des
autres et de ce point de vue là le
masque est un élément
fondamental et on s'est aperçu que
mettre le masque
ça permettait de redevenir
ce que l'on est et de ne pas être ce que
seulement ce que l'on pense que l'autre
souhaite que l'on soit
je pense que à partir du moment où il y
a eu le masque et le début du combat
assez rapidement je pense que le ils ont
oublié qu'ils avaient fini les garçons
tout simplement parce qu'il y avait une
formation qui ne faisait pas de
différence les filles
ont été prises en charge comme les
garçons avec les mêmes exercices les
mêmes exigences etc à partir de là assez
rapidement ça s'est bien passé
était très forte en esprit beaucoup et
on m'a dit que tu gagnais les garçons tu
gagnes les garçons non
jouer avec une fille déjà ça veut dire
que cette fille là c'est un
parce que si quelqu'un tu as avec
quelqu'un ça veut dire que vous avez une
certaine égalité de statut de force etc
donc ça veut dire que cette personne là
peut vous défier peut vous battre et que
cette fille là vous batte ça vous aide à
vous
réinventer mais aussi retrouver une
identité parce qu'on apprend en respect
cette à respecter cette femme là si on
commence par respecter cette femme là et
peut-être qu'à travers elle aussi vous
respecterez toutes les autres filles et
que vous apprendrez à respecter votre
halte et que soit et se donner à cette
fille là aussi une confiance en elle et
le fait de donner à cette fille là cette
opportunité là de confronter à un garçon
c'est lui montrer que ce garçon-là c'est
pas un être c'est pas il y a pas de
supériorité aussi bien au niveau de
force
etc etc grâce à l'escrime on parle aux
filles là-bas c'est interdit
il y a le quartier femme tu peux pas
causer avec les filles donc là à cause
de l'escrime on peut parler avec les
filles avec les garçons avec Monsieur
Niels avec tout le monde
[Musique]
quand vous regardez les Asics les procès
la plupart des cas pour les femmes c'est
des cas des
cadres quand il y a un fantastique c'est
parce que ce sont des grossesses non
désirées
[Musique]
le débat sur l'avortement médicalisé en
cas de viol ou d'inceste a été relancé
au Sénégal il s'agit aujourd'hui d'une
question de santé publique le code pénal
du Sénégal adepte en 1962 une peine de
prison pour les femmes ayant recours à
l'avortement
la loi est confirmée en 2005 les jeunes
filles accouchent ton seul dans des
conditions dramatiques qui entraîne le
plus souvent la mort d'une nouveau-né
elles sont accusées d'avortement
clandestin ou d'infanticide poursuivi
aux assises et condamnés à de lourdes
peines d'emprisonnement il aurait
rarement proposé les sons obstétriques
nécessaires
l'Association pour le sourd d'un enfant
a construit un poste de santé dans le
quartier à blayakin l'un des quartiers
les plus pauvres de la ville de Thiès
[Musique]
moi je suis sage de trouver des jeunes
filles de 13 ans qui sont
qui ont commencé à pratiquer l'acte
sexuel
elles ont subi de la pédophilie à bas
âge
sans le dire
puis si elle trouve quelqu'un pour
quelqu'un qui est mal intentionné qui
leur donne de l'argent
elles peuvent faire ça comme comment
c'est très souvent c'est genre de fille
là qui évolue avec des grossesses
quand c'est une grossesse non désirée
des fois elle se cache elles peuvent
continuer la grossesse jusqu'à
l'âge d'accouchement bon
elle peut fuguer à ce moment
et accoucher ailleurs très souvent c'est
pas des femmes ces jeunes filles là
elles n'accroche pas au sein de la
maison elle a que ce soit au bord de la
mer dans des cabanes
il y a des gens qui les assistent à ce
moment-là
[Musique]
arrêter la grossesse ou accoucher
autre part que nous avons besoin
elle creuse
ou bien elle trouve un sachet un sac
poubelle n'importe quel type pour
envelopper l'enfant
[Musique]
c'est les jeunes filles qui sont à peine
majeures
elles sont souvent à l'école avec toutes
les conséquences qu'on sait parce que
même si la loi à l'interdit au Sénégal
les filles sont systématiquement
renvoyées quand elles tombent enceinte
c'est ça
stigmatisation une forte stigmatisation
et vont se retrouver
rejetées par les croyances
et enfermé donc là on peut parler c'est
pas une double peine c'est quatre fois
la peine en fait
c'est plusieurs peines à la fois quel
que soit l'origine de cette grossesse
précoce non désirée elle
elle se la violence de la situation se
traduisait chez elle par un abandon de
leur corps c'est à dire elle le
délaissait complètement comme s'il y
avait une dissociation entre leur esprit
et leur corps et donc l'important c'est
de réunir les deux pour qu'il y ait
effectivement réparation et l'Escrime
qui
est exigeant en fait en termes physiques
et de posture
la vie la Bible et de nouveau le masque
le rond permis progressivement presque à
leur insu en fait de se réapproprier
leur corps et de réconcilier leur esprit
et leur corps on avait espoir que
effectivement comme ça avait été quelque
chose de conçu avec des professionnels
de l'escrime et des professionnels de la
santé mentale qu'il y ait un effet mais
un effet
ce point là et surtout dans la durée
c'est à dire que les jeunes qui ont qui
sont la première promotion comme l'on
dit c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont pratiqué
en 2012
aujourd'hui encore si on les rencontre
ils expliquent dans leur vie actuelle
ce qu'ils ont appris à travers l'escrime
c'est à dire vivre autrement un certain
nombre de valeurs qui leur donnent une
autre place de la société et bien c'est
aussi ce qui structure encore
aujourd'hui leur vie donc ça c'est un
effet incroyable
les années passées
mais à cause que vous il est devenu un
garçon normal
[Musique]
la maman elle dit que tu es un joli cœur
on est perdu Nice
on est en train de chercher un enfant
casser de la prison mais on sait pas où
il faut aller
on va trouver mais on est au milieu du
Sénégal dans un endroit où on voit bien
en train de devenir un désert
n'a pas de GPS ça marche pas
[Musique]
à table
est-ce que tu as envie de me dire
pourquoi et combien de temps tu as été à
la MAC si tu veux pas tu me dis pas
[Musique]
accusé
de vol combien de temps tu as fait dans
la prison
[Musique]
de moi et quand tu es rentré dans la
prison tu avais quel âge
et ça t'a fait quoi de rentrer en prison
au début
[Rires]
les gens qui passent par le programme
d'escrime à la MAC de Thiès et récidive
pas pourquoi tu penses que l'escrime les
aide est-ce que
ça t'ouvre les yeux et ça ouvre l'esprit
et à la sortie tu sais déjà ce que tu
dois faire après quoi
tu as joué avec des filles
et tu gagnais ou tu perdais
[Rires]
est-ce que votre fils il a changé avec
les screen
mais il sait comment l'enfant réfléchit
et passe beaucoup avant de faire quelque
chose
et les a tous abandonnés
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est le poulet Jacques
ouais c'est un cadeau
[Musique]
merci à vous tous
[Rires]
[Musique]
parmi les plus de 400 mineurs maintenant
qui ont pratiqué l'escrime selon cette
méthode en milieu carcéral
et bien aucun arrêt civilé donc voilà un
reviendra ou une reviendra
inévitablement mais en tous les cas là
le résultat est au-delà de nos
espérances ça c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
pendant le tournage de ce documentaire
je faisais en même temps un film de
fiction avec le chanteur dadju qui était
en concert à Dakar je lui ai proposé de
venir voir l'association avec son équipe
[Musique]
pour
leur permettre de se reconstruire
marché
c'est impressionnant quand même
avant tous ces enfants aller à la prison
en fait et on a négocié avec les
magistrats petit à petit qui soit confié
ici plutôt que d'aller à la prison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
[Rires]
c'est quand même quelque chose quelque
chose d'incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci les gars merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
ça a été conçu pour les mineurs en
détention et puis on s'aperçoit que ça
peut s'adresser à aussitôtres enfants
qui ont eu des petits accidents dans
leur vie voilà
quand on faisait d'autres sports avant
ils avaient l'habitude de se battre
ou bien de montrer des trucs de force
en dehors de l'esprit sur la vie
[Applaudissements]
des enfants apprendre plus qu'avant
dans un premier temps
leur attention et aussi la socialisation
c'est à dire ils ont plus de
responsabilités
à la société
cette magnifique méthode prouve que l'on
peut juger un individu avoir un avis sur
lui mais que cet individu peut changer
profondément la condamnation sans retour
possible est clairement dangereuse ces
ados ont prouvé qu'il pouvait évoluer
intrinsèquement c'est la beauté de
l'homme
[Musique]
une seule défaite
qu'est-ce qui vous fait tenir depuis 30
ans
ce que ça fait 30 ans quand même
c'est naturel et je crois quand même que
il y a des moments privilégiés des
moments de
au cœur de l'homme quoi vraiment
on
est à la rencontre de
ce qui est intrinsèque chez l'homme même
si ce sont des jeunes on est là on
touche du doigt la réalité humaine et le
bonheur de la rencontre et ensuite
ça peut paraître bateau ce que je veux
dire mais
je sais pas quand on sait d'où viennent
ces enfants comment ils arrivent et
qu'on les voit redevenir des enfants
ou redevenir des jeunes et puis pour les
plus grands de ne venir des vrais
moments et des vrais papas
je pense qu'elle consciemment ça doit
quand même
ressourcer et régénérer les batteries
[Musique]